Don't make me angry you
wouldn't like me when i'm angry
Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel
she-hulk video there's been reports that it's
going to feature a bunch of cameo scenes from
other old and new marvel characters way more than
you see in the trailer like abomination in the
trailers coming back obviously but there's way
more surprise characters than that and now there's
reports that one of those new ones is going to be
one of the fantastic four characters so i'll
explain what's going on i will be doing videos for
all the episodes when it starts in a couple weeks
we're almost there and we have comic con this week
there's going to be a huge marvel comic con panel
this year we're supposed to get the black panther
2 trailer footage and previews from a bunch of
other movies in disney plus series like what if
season 2 the x-men revival series ant-man 3 some
more news about the upcoming fantastic four movie
that they're working on so be sure to subscribe
to get all those videos i'll do as many trailer
videos and as many announcements and bonus videos
as possible it's going to be awesome but the big
news this past week is that there's going to be a
big fantastic four cameo scene during the she-hulk
series it's going to be nine episodes long and
it's supposed to have a bunch of different cameos
not just the ones that you've seen in the trailer
like tim ross abomination obviously is coming back
he's a really big character metaphorically and
literally but like charlie cox's daredevil is
also supposed to have cameo scenes i don't
know how many episodes he's going to be in
but i will talk about him more in a second
the big thing reportedly is that a version of
the thing is supposed to have a cameo seen
in the series but the reports don't say
whether or not it would be a ben grimm cameo scene
like he be human form ben graham or a full-blown
thing cameo scene like willie have already gotten
his powers and the reports don't say whether or
not it's going to be the 616 main mcu version or
if it's another multiverse cameo scene kind of
like the doctor strange 2 fantastic four cameo
scenes there's been reports that we're going
to learn more about the upcoming fantastic four
movie at comic con this year even though it's not
going to come out for a couple years even though
everyone has been fan casting new fantastic four
characters we just saw john krasinski as reed
richards in the doctor strange 2 movie that was
the 838 version of the character and he was killed
by scarlet witch so rip838 reed richards and
rip illuminati just in general all these reports
about the new fantastic four movie say they might
cast completely different characters for all the
616 versions of the characters they'd need a new
version of reed richards no matter what and
i think we just assumed that they'd keep john
krasinski and say that it was a version of the
team from another universe but now it kind of
sounds like there's going to be a legit 616 main
mcu version of the team i believe the early theory
right now is that ant-man 3 will tease the team
in a much bigger way early theories that because
we'd probably see the origin story during the new
solo movie down the road it would be the human
form version of ben grimm having a cameo scene
not like full blown thing having a cameo scene
the reports are also saying that it might be jason
segel playing the character which isn't someone i
would have expected before this but that's just a
rumor so you can let me know what you think about
jason segel playing a version of the thing can we
just talk about something hmm how amazing is rush
um excuse me how amazing is rush amazing amazing
amazing remember whoever they wind up casting is
the character when they do full-blown versions
of the thing in the new fantastic four movie
they would do it just like they do the special
effects for the whole character like some motion
capture in some full cg combination so it'd be
more like the voice of whoever this actor winds
up being in his face plastered onto a massive
cg character as opposed to the classic version
the thing that we saw in the old fantastic four
movies that they mostly did as a practical effect
i'll take the stairs
so like a really good example for the way they do
their powers would be doctor strange too they say
that a lot of that movie was meant to be a test
run just to see what a version the fantastic four
at least reed richards powers would look like
done in the traditional mcu movie style just a
combination of practical effects with cg for their
powers the joke about reed richards being turned
into spaghetti by scarlet witch is that it was
actually kevin feige who came up with the idea
to do that not sam raimi who said to kill him
off in that way kevin feige's like let's turn
him into spaghetti that should look pretty cool
it was a pretty crazy way to go out they wanted
her to have pretty cool takedowns for some of the
characters although my favorite deaths that were
talking about favorite dez on the illuminati would
actually be read richard's spaghetti and the scene
of her getting professor x while they were inside
her mind there's been all kinds of rumors about
who they'll cast as the other versions of the
616 fantastic four characters so i'll probably
wait till they make some more announcements
about that movie until i do another video
but i think it's a pretty easy assumption to
make that we will see cameo scenes from the 616
fantastic four characters in other people's movies
before the actual solo movie starts the other big
news recently was the 616 mcu doctor doom because
he's a core fantastic four character obviously
he's related to a lot of this i just did a black
panther 2 doctor doom video because he's supposed
to be important for the plot of that movie so i
will post a link for that video at the end of this
and down in the description below so you can learn
all about how they get into doctor doom through
the black panther 2 movie it's a very marvel kind
of thing where you tease people behind the scenes
pulling strings and then reveal them later on
a very thanos type of reveal for mcu doctor
doom speaking of big secret reveals in the thing
they were actually supposed to have a version of
the fantastic four crossing over in deadpool 2 way
back when they were still making that movie at fox
this is way before the disney deal ever went
down when they were trying to figure out what
that movie was going to be they wound up replacing
that with the x-force plot but originally what was
going to happen is because they had just rebooted
the fantastic four movie they were gonna bring
a version of the thing into the movie and we're
gonna see deadpool with the thing they'd workshop
some versions of the scenes but what ended up
happening is that tim miller wound up leaving the
project and ryan reynolds basically took over the
movie and he's the person that was responsible for
all the x-force stuff once upon a time when fox
still had the rights they were also planning on
doing their own captain america civil war type of
movie where they sort of cross over all the x-men
characters with all the fantastic four characters
but it was going to be a version of johnny storm
that kind of sets things off it was going to be
a very different type of captain america civil
war type of plot but it was the same basic concept
it was going to be their big in-universe crossover
before marvel got the rights back i did a video
a while ago too about marvel's current plans
for charlie cox's daredevil and kingpin inside the
mcu because they're sort of the tip of the iceberg
like they came back during spiderman no way home
in hawkeye and they're the tip of the iceberg
for them sort of re-canonizing or canonizing
most of the marvel netflix stuff most of those
actors coming back in some form in the future in
the mcu not everybody but most of them right now
the plan just starts with some of the daredevil
characters in the next couple of years mostly
having them show up in other people's disney plus
series like daredevil is supposed to be part of
the she-hulk series jessica jones kristen
ritter rumored to come back during that too
daredevil kingpin and some of the other daredevil
netflix characters are supposed to come back again
during the echo series and that's supposed to feel
kind of like a daredevil season 4 unofficially
in longer term like a couple years down the road
the scuttlebutt is i've mentioned before marvel
doing a full-blown daredevil disney plus series
revival with most of the characters coming back
like everybody gets new costumes like daredevil
will get a new daredevil costume when he shows up
as daredevil in the mcu like we saw him as matt
murdock during spiderman no way home the next time
he shows up we'll probably see him as daredevil
with a new daredevil costume but all these
characters will still have the same vibe as they
did during the netflix episodes vincent d'onofrio
even said during all his interviews on the hawkeye
series he was playing the same version of kingpin
from the daredevil netflix series he had the exact
same cufflinks he was even wearing the same black
suit in one of those deleted scenes when you talk
about organized crime in the marvel universe and
you talk about the cd underbelly of new york city
there is one primary character that comes to mind
he said i want to bring you into the mcu and
i'm not going to say no to that like that's
pretty awesome but when they bring some of these
characters back like kingpin for example they did
the special featurette on disney plus that you've
probably seen the marvel producers said that they
wanted to do a slightly different version of
kingpin like they wanted to do more heavyset
version but they kind of changed their minds about
that so they wanted to tune some of the creative
behind his character but essentially he's the
same version from the daredevil netflix episodes
it'll be the same thing with all the other marvel
netflix characters pretty much the same versions
of the characters which is slight creative
retunings like different costumes and it's
not like they're gonna come back referencing
every single thing that they ever did in all
those episodes even though comic-con is this week
i'm not expecting to get a brand new she-hulk
trailer until maybe next week or the week after
but they will start dropping more trailers soon
but i think what they'll probably do is take the
typical marvel approach where they don't put all
the really cool stuff in the trailers like they
won't put charlie cox's daredevil in the trailer
if he's gonna cameo during the series reportedly
during the series he's gonna be both matt murdock
and we'll see him in a daredevil costume doing
vigilante stuff but it'll be a new mcu version
of the costume i did a separate daredevil video a
little while ago too about the other new costume
that he's supposed to get during the echo series
because he's going to be a big character during
that and then later during his daredevil revival
series another new black costume like the brand
new all new all different type of costume so
the biggest question a lot of you have been
asking me now the past few days is does this mean
that all the netflix shows and agents of shield
are now totally canon 100 to the mcu like are they
bringing everybody back inside the mcu now and the
answer is no not totally like they don't have big
plans to bring back iron fist any time soon mike
coulter said that there are currently no plans to
bring back his version of luke cage right now yes
coulson did come back in the captain marvel movie
but that was because it took place in the 90s when
he was younger and still alive in the mcu before
he'd been killed by loki during the avengers movie
i'll be posting marvel comic-con videos all
week long so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new black panther 2
doctor doom video and click here for my brand new
mandalorian season 3 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!